welcome back to new rock stars I'm
marina masters and Joker's last laugh
has lasted months and months thanks to
making a billion dollars and winning a
ton of awards and it still isn't cinema
enough for Scorsese but it is for us
because ever since we've gotten the
movie in HD we've been coming back
through this movie in search of all the
interesting visual elements we
overlooked in the first breakdown it may
be light on comic book references but
there are actually a ton of hidden
details that make this movie really
great
go watch Eric's first breakdown for some
solid analysis and good old-fashioned
clue huntin but here let's recap this
egg let's get started the opening shot
of the movie might actually hide a very
cool visual easter egg in many viewers
eyes the shape of Arthur flecks mirror
and the reflection of the lights creates
the image of Batman's cowl holy [ __ ]
sure this could be pareidolia the
phenomenon of seeing faces and
everything but Eric says it's new
rockstars policy that faces actually are
in everything so if it was intentional
by director Todd Phillips this would
actually be a pretty cool statement of
the way this movie reframes the hero of
Gotham the sympathetic damaged soul who
covers his face and becomes Gotham's
knight in this movie is the man who
laughs and Arthur here positioned in the
mouth region of the hero face will in
the final minutes christened himself a
hero by making his mouth his iconic
facial feature we get our first glimpse
at Arthur's uncontrollable after which
Joaquin Phoenix based on real-life
patients suffering from pathological
laughter check out an episode of the big
question where Eric broke down how this
illness functions and how way more
people than you realize actually suffer
from it but my favorite detail about
Arthur's laughs is how Phoenix evolved
it throughout the film to convey his
characters journey according to Todd
Phillips they developed three stages of
the left first stage they called the
affliction laugh Arthur is powerless to
it and it expresses his pain the second
stage they called the one of the guys
laugh it emerges in act two when Arthur
starts to become more comfortable with
himself and others like when he laughs
in Thomas Waynes face the third stage
only emerges in the final act the
authentic joy laughs Arthur sweetly
releases it after shooting Murray
and really truly in the final scene when
speaking with a psychologist
now that ending scene was deliberately
designed to be ambiguous with Todd
Phillips suggesting the ending was meant
to leave us with open-ended
possibilities for the Joker story like
Alan Moore did with The Killing Joke one
big clue that many people point to comes
up in this early scene with Arthur's
social worker Deborah Kane and have you
thought more about why you were locked
up this kind of way is the same lighting
and color tone is the final scene and
notice the clock 11:11 back in the
social workers office the clock also
raises 11:11 in fact every time we see a
clock in the movie it is 11:11 the time
you customarily make a wish and also
11:11 is my birthday you can interpret
the whole movie as taking place in this
mental hospital the events are a wishful
dreams scenario by Arthur a joke none of
us would get having the movie in HD also
allows us to terrify ourselves by
reading every last word in his joke
notebook what a rant describes a
homeless man passed out on the street
after being stepped over whom Arthur
suspects could be dead Deborah reads the
line I just hope my death makes more
sense than my life it's not a bad pun
but it only works in writing not spoken
out loud too bad
Twitter didn't exist in 1981 but the
deeper meaning of this line gets
revealed later in the film
Arthur rereads the line to himself on
his talk show when his original plan was
to kill himself
but he realized that suicide would make
his life senseless and instead by
killing Murray it would make his journal
a manifesto in Arthur's apartment
there's a print of a painting above the
TV this is the blue boy by Thomas
Gainsborough this same painting showed
up in the Tim Burton Batman the scene
when that Joker danced at the Museum the
comedian at the club that Arthur
observes is actually a real comic named
Gary Gulman his bit about role-playing
with his girlfriend his actual material
Goleman does on his 2012 album no can
defend the three [ __ ] who jump
Arthur on the train yell at him to stay
down while they beat him up
this sets up the reversal of Arthur's
fortunes at the end of the film when
after being freed from the police car at
the Riding clowns tell him to get up all
the way when Arthur shoots the guys he
fires a total of eight shots without
reloading
this could be a common movie firearm
gaff or summer interpreting this as
another piece of evidence that all these
events are actually just within Arthur's
imagination also the harassment it looks
kind of like the same woman Arthur sees
wearing the first clown mask in the back
of the taxi as the news of the murders
begins to spread after confronting
Thomas Wayne there's the odd moment
Arthur closes himself inside the
refrigerator there's a fun editing trick
here in the way that the imagery syncs
up with the audio while Arthur empties
the fridge we hear the voice from
detective Garrity and then after he
closes the fridge door a few more
seconds passed and then the phone rings
again
[Music]
that phone call was from a later scene
when Arthur is back out of the fridge so
the editor uses this sound effect to
blur the line between the passage of
time to disorient us on the chronology
and make it deliberately confusing as to
how the hell Arthur got out of that
fridge he's basically Indiana Jones and
by the way the fridge appears in a later
scene undisturbed without its contents
on the floor in front of it so who knows
in order to keep the budget down Todd
Phillips kept the cgi in the film to a
minimum one of the few CGI shots in the
film is Arthur walking up to Arkham
state hospital we know there's a VFX
here because this building is the
Brooklyn Army terminal annex building
they had to add Arkham state hospital to
the wall Arthur's final Joker face paint
was designed to look more matte than
glossy with the blues and reds totally
subdued the makeup artist said they
didn't want the makeup to reflect in the
light so that it would fit with the
muted color palette of the film the red
paint is a reddish brown color that
resembles blood so that it would blend
in with the blood Arthur uses to widen
his smile right before this while Arthur
is briefly detained in the police car
there's a shot of him leaning his head
against the window looking out at the
riots and celebration this parallels the
shot of Heath Ledger's Joker in the Dark
Knight who stuck his head out the cop
car window celebrating his freedom the
shot of Arthur also calls back to one of
the early shots in the film with him
glumly looking out the bus window
he was once trapped beaten down but now
he gets the last laugh he's a psychopath
in one early draft of the film rather
than smearing blood on his cheeks
Arthur was going to use a shard of
broken glass to carve a Glasgow smile
into past wounds that would have been
there from a time in his childhood that
he cut a slight smile into his face to
scare off bullies that would freak me
out too yeah another alternate ending
from an early script draft would have
had Arthur escaping the studio after
killing Murray
the riot would have spread to Wayne
Manor and the rioters would have dragged
out Thomas and Martha to execute them
just like Marie Antoinette and Lew the
sixteenth then Arthur would have shown
up at their funeral been spotted and
chased down until getting hit by a car
and captured there were also reports of
yet another alternate ending in which
the joke that Arthur was laughing at in
the
would have been seen Arthur himself
killing Thomas and Martha and then
spinning around to shoot young Bruce to
to stop his crying but as we've learned
time and time again the truth of this
Joker story is best left as multiple
choice comment down below with your
interpretation of this ink blot test of
a movie if I didn't cover a detail in
this video like Deborah Caine's name the
movies on the marquee the ace and the
whole lounge there's a good chance that
Eric already covered all that stuff in
his first breakdown it's a great video
so go check it out and also I'm just one
person like I can't do everything Eric
does he's been doing this for years and
I've been doing this for like five
minutes
give me a break people follow me on
social media following new rockstars and
subscribe to new rock stars from our
movie analysis and for the movies that
are just unavoidably violent we've
started offering bonus premium
breakdowns to our generous patrons a
frame-by-frame analysis of the church
seen in Kingsman or a scene-by-scene
breakdown of the shining get all these
and more by becoming a patron today at
patreon.com slash new rock stars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]